okay [ __ ] uh okay yeah [ __ ] yes um
so we are playing the last of us here
it's your boy psycho [ __ ] babble um
you know it's a sunday it's feeling good
so works you're not gonna have like a
time limit on those you know like
usually I just [ __ ] like like I had
see with the chopper and I just like
stop it there start it up again but you
know I'm feeling good so I'm probably
gonna play a lot so you know like you
might not have a smooth transition to
the next couple episode but [ __ ] it you
know i'm here to entertain not secure ID
[ __ ] I know curator that's for sure
I've been kicked out of a lot of museums
and it is not time for that okay so
let's just sit back and enjoy the show
okay okay no what am I swamp monster now
I name of town I was just too rich for
my blood rich for his plot okay um there
were past lot lot ties and racers in
Blood Bones he's finally Clarion to
likes to mix traces sooo we can find too
high when I just boost you up hey how
some good stuff here [ __ ] ass I'll take
this thank you very much how can i make
anything oh oh oh no no no pop hey this
is my father got stupid oh I really miss
golfing oh [ __ ] yeah they probably do
[ __ ] miss coffee it's not something
you can really like import in Apocalypse
okay let's let's looking out of here can
i get 0 I just Anna okay okay Jennifer
you check to you things up here Oh brick
hey [ __ ] up here call me Jenny from the
block look at me with like a thousand
five and arrows and [ __ ] well are trying
to be Darryl from the walk-in dead I
guess this is before the walking dead
right I can't I don't even know we're
not gonna start it it's gonna [ __ ] out
okay oh no no no no no put it down put
it down God Jesus I can't people all
right combat just got a DC on it Oh
Ellie you're the one that said we should
go up here so maybe usually do I am i
leading hey right now my gosh you
followed here oh I just might we done
here my chess
okay what you got an iconic who will
swap this I guess hey bone pastor I
heard him oh [ __ ] cover me i'm open up
[ __ ] a well I handle that like pretty
well I have to say you just find out
where this pitch is going oh sure keep
it up pal Oh shet chukka pitch out ah
you see that daddy don't play daddy do
not oh [ __ ] ready ready Emily get him oh
wait for this kind of come in you just
saved this guy is gonna check where she
going where is he going lost on this
ain't good
[ __ ] playing a fling
take it easy everything's cool man no
yeah [ __ ] yeah that's what I say [ __ ] ok
ok let me get these goodies that oh man
what it's like you're surprised like
that this is how the Royal does ok Jake
hey I care check here nothing nothing
yeah this is just how I want to nothing
here biter sense nothing wow they look
seal these doors the [ __ ] um hey this I
need it that's I rags no no condom your
load ok let's look around here any gut
is any goodies is this like a thorough I
[ __ ] it
that's in here oh thank ya Mackay same
shits forward with the [ __ ] is full no
that safe in there yes all I could take
the [ __ ] save yeah okay back in here
before I murder that guy no is this oh
ok I like don't works better than called
bottles right one makes more noise than
the other and what better for damage
nothin s JTP think it just heard
something let me check real quick
nothing nothing just a whole bunch I'm
not then ni way
where is he where is a [ __ ] jet oh dude
are you gonna hide [ __ ] he's gonna
stand there oh [ __ ] you know what that
is let's do this ouch make it this [ __ ]
no huh
Oh shed I did not see that oh oh you
want to die to pitch ooh I love me some
mild tubs yeah i forgot i had a bunch of
them okay okay as you could see I'm
doing the strongman approach I'll just
kind of just going on through oh yeah I
know yeah what else over there this guy
got good both I know he does
okay let me just check around here watch
out watch out chase us then in here and
get the ink and not say anything
oh [ __ ] this accoutred what's in here
okay grab stuff oof yes as you're
checking around a room here I guess Rex
Oh paper [ __ ] a thank ya this is make
anything now hmm first faster I guess
what's out here wait am I trying to get
to ain't I trying to get to the bridge
okay looking around oh hello I like that
I can hear the canopies
are you like we rats in here okay I no
one know we're supposed to go push your
scalp stairs yeah okay I thought I saw
some here enough coffee hey it looks
like there's a ladder inside this
elevator hold up lemme try to open it Oh
badshah me just make sure nothing here
that we rented she anything in there why
am I trying to live gonna lot of noise
I'm trying like what some falling right
here let's see where this goes oh [ __ ]
now we're getting like splinter cell e
what the [ __ ] that looks like a way
through kind of cramp it came here like
a think in here well let me look around
with work
it looks like it looks like a white
through but how exactly he's supposed to
possess turbines oh we're here it'll be
a tight fit but come on okay over here
oh [ __ ] Wow can you be a little more
gentle like okay you finally some to
climb oh I can't eat jump up it doesn't
seem high okay okay all icons I around
okay oh yeah okay all right well let me
just see it no stay out there I'll make
my way up to you kalyan just looking at
here okay a little time nothing do it
okay okay there's gonna be [ __ ]
zombies in the I know there's
you're talking no they're zombies in
here the music has changed that is
certain there are [ __ ] zombies in
here and I'm not excited to see them
ok
okay thank you over this
this is gonna be great this is gonna be
great and on time for this [ __ ] but you
know right alive helped in our live that
doorway what was that oh sad that
[ __ ] shotgun ammo I do not like the
sign of those [ __ ] who kind of
crapped out I can't graft anything that
[ __ ] sucks
okay careful now oh I can't even I can't
even go low right now I need to find a
way around this gate
can't swim so
this is gonna be [ __ ] scary okay
oh [ __ ] okay okay there's a scary one no
I and I make him go faster is that kind
of taking his time here gosh probably
like in great shape get out David spores
all right I don't hear anything oh [ __ ]
is that rats
I do not like the side of this they're
really loaded me up nah shut
not great oh I hear clicking this place
is rocking and fast it this is just like
[ __ ] a rave at home in [ __ ] half
life okay I'm just I'm not ready for
this okay great right I need the key
card
[ __ ] alright I guess I'm doing the
studly
can I hide man this yeah I don't see
them are they behind the door now okay
go check out
[ __ ] is going on here come on grab him
grab a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] come on fight this
batch another one here great great
that's good I hear one that's like
[ __ ] running around
Ellen's [ __ ] running around like a
maniac [ __ ] I can't see it looks it
going
[ __ ] I'll bet that get it ok this [ __ ]
doesn't want to meet me and I don't want
to meet him so [ __ ]
just tell me where I gotta go [ __ ] what
was that I hear something but I don't
know where the [ __ ] is coming from or is
it I'll I just need a key card on
that cat [ __ ]
I got you a [ __ ] you just got served it
just got served running around like a
maniac and ain't gonna get you nowhere
oops where's that they're like electric
the water
damn it
what now oh [ __ ] here's another one [ __ ]
a lot of them they look like pigs
Conrail re lat
okay i need like a key card right
who
what is this like this SMS
what's in here
and I come through this way does it seem
so familiar
yeah something I right I'm not gonna get
it okay well I definitely turn this on
so I'm probably skip my stuff here good
do I have one no look at that
I'm cheap anything in here [ __ ]
probably already dead these lights go to
something right oh yeah this is where I
like took down like 30 people okay she
said key card required somewhere here's
a year [ __ ] like a [ __ ] here key card
shot like 80 people
key card key card looking for my key
card oh this is every year that is this
no want that need a key card just I'm
just rummaging around like in five
[ __ ] cake I'd oh okay what's over
here what's over here bottle no no I'm
ain't down I need a cake I'd well when I
turn Allah generators a lot of bodies
there you can t kiko there
how'd it be down there over here like
there's a lot of bodies here I do
anything
yeah [ __ ] fun like a cat bamix okay
it's gotta be like an office right it's
like an office although some follow
those hint I'll find a key card thank
you the [ __ ] was that
they're a lot of [ __ ] in this game
well I got to say hey I'm not big on you
miss fight yeah Jess okay oh I know I'm
going now makes a lot faster lolok a
ball I hear there's definitely a [ __ ]
here I hear them well I get [ __ ] out
here so much for that we gotta find
Ellie that's [ __ ] horrible anything
in here had anything hit it no no sock
an awful that's like actually awful ing
silent yeah I think I'll take this prick
No thank you I'm now I'm not a brook man
okay oh hello daddy shadi left capacity
hey ranch I don't know no your riddle it
pretty quickly honey bucket waiting for
something good in here dict ass thank
you I still hear this i hear got a
[ __ ] click in there is like a [ __ ]
guy here well i don't i don't understand
what that is but ok can you hear him
catch it I got it nicely done bit not
today you not today not today all right
spread out make sure we didn't miss any
more of these [ __ ]
he saves me I'm gonna have to grab him
knockout think you're [ __ ] hurt
something okay cat okay okay well that
settles that oh maybe I should kill
myself yeah in a while
you think get here any like rob or
anything my gosh my like hungry don't
talk about that babe i hungry know if
this yeah the [ __ ] is that now what the
[ __ ]
your [ __ ] like sizzling now try this way
yeah I came into this way what my going
here I losing it came in through here I
can way through there over here I like
to always have one okay see here see
here [ __ ] everywhere I can't give it man
over here yeah thank you now I gotta go
up there I gotta find a [ __ ] ladder i
guess not a move this right now remember
that oh very good hmm
I'm up that's thank you oh oh oh given
that water's there you know I'm already
started pressing pressing Oh is he gonna
right there yeah get it get it come on
come on just pick it up pick it up Chris
and Ally huh oh God thank y le yeah i
saw the hell out of that guy huh hey you
sure did yeah I feel sick and you just
hang back like I told you to well you're
glad I didn't write I'm glad I didn't
get my head blown off by goddamn kid you
know what know how about hey Ellie I
know it wasn't easy but it was either
him or me thanks for saving my ass you
got anything like that for me Joel oh
yeah huh anyway anything yes we got to
get going that's [ __ ] [ __ ] back an
[ __ ] I come back up yeah I can't deck
no as I say take dexter and Neville to
your moms no all right good care oh it's
[ __ ] up up top good i reload this [ __ ]
every cool factory loaded oh no we have
it up here like they're okay and deck
eatin [ __ ] it's maybe I could build a
Casio watch No anyclip the other one
that is all these like things they put
on everything okay I'm decadence second
that cat we need to get back out find
that bridge hate this crap yeah that in
here ain't [ __ ] here you get the [ __ ]
out of here dr. i have like too much
ammo I feel like I'm very anti stellt
and very assault in here so i don't know
how i have like too much ammo like a
persistent problem oh look at this isaac
golden any weapons oh thank god Jesus
hmm [ __ ] what the [ __ ] happen here that
door looks like a way out oh you see a
way to get up there nope wow look at
that either I'd say a backdrop people
would take their pictures in front of it
yeah I know what it is I make anything
now who can't close it makes my health
Oh baby Peppa need a baby back thank you
that I get that yeah
okay how to get up there Oh she'd like
to move the piano is that what they
[ __ ] up like a lot I'll be able to get
there with theirs I talked about it nice
if I could talk medical yep all right
i'll move it's gonna be a lot of [ __ ]
noise but [ __ ] it you know all right
yeah bout a hand you sure you can trust
me with that le bouche it's harder there
how's that I made a lot of [ __ ] noise
let's go okay let's like it like we
gotta get the [ __ ] out you hear
something
I know it shout for her Amish